owusu day nichts geht mehr der tag an
dem unsere erde verbraucht ist jetzt
wirklich zum science fiction regierende
war für das sagt der croupier im casino
nichts geht mehr wenn unsere erde könnte
würde sie genau jetzt dasselbe sagen
denn es ist so nichts geht mehr
forscher des global footprint networks
und der new economics foundation haben
wir jedes jahr den usa today berechnet
mit einem beängstigenden resultat aber
das ist genau dieser overshoot day in
einer pressemitteilung auf der website
von overshoot day dot org heißt es zitat
der social day markiert den tag an dem
wir aus ökologischer sicht über unsere
verhältnisse leben
das bedeutet dass die menschheit vom
ersten januar bis zum 8 august so viel
von der natur verbraucht hat wie die
erde im ganzen jahre generieren kann
der mehrverbrauch ist möglich weil wir
mehr co2 in die atmosphäre ausstoßen
können als unsere ozeane und wälder
absorbieren weil wir schneller fischen
können
als sich die fischbestände erholen und
wir bäume schneller fällen können als
sie nachwachsen
zitat ende in zwei info grafiken
veranschaulichen die forscher zum einen
wie viele länder nötig sind um den
verbrauch der jeweiligen einwohner zu
decken und zum anderen wie viele erden
man benötigen würde wenn alle menschen
so leben würden wie zum beispiel in
australien
schauen wir uns die erste grafik mal ein
wenig genauer an die einwohner
frankreichs verbrauchen rund 150 prozent
der ressourcen die ihr eigenes land zur
verfügung stellen kann um die rund 1 5
milliarden menschen in china ausreichend
versorgen zu kommen können werden über
350 prozent der chinesischen ressourcen
nötig aber das kann noch gesteigert
werden südkoreas einwohner verbrauchen
das achtfache der eigenen
versorgungsgüter ok kommen wir jetzt mal
zu der zweiten grafik würden alle
menschen auf dem gesamten planeten leben
wie hier in deutschland dann wären 3,1
erden pro jahr nötig um eine versorgung
sicherzustellen
wenn wir alle so leben würden wie die
australier dann wären es sogar 54 erden
etwas besser sieht es da im gegensatz zu
der lebensweise die in australien
vorherrscht mit der lebensweise in
indien aus wie indoor ebenso
rücksichtsvoll würden wir alle die
ressourcen so schonend wie auch nur die
ressourcen dieser erde bräuchten in der
realität sieht das aber leider bei
weitem schlechter aus wir verbrauchen ab
duell so wie wir alle auf unsere eigene
art und weise leben die ressourcen von
rund 1,6 erden wir leben also über
unsere verhältnisse das klimaabkommen
von paris ist bis jetzt das deutlichste
zeichen für die notwendigkeit den co2
fußabdruck drastisch zu reduzieren am
ende haben wir die wahl zwischen
stabilität oder kollaps wir empfehlen
nationen städten und individuen vehement
in aktion zu treten und die pariser
ziele zu einer greifbaren realität zu
machen ein zitat von matthias
wackernagel ceo von global footprint
network alle 195 teilnehmenden staaten
haben das abkommen dass 2020 in kraft
treten wird unterzeichnet
aber was genau steht eigentlich in
diesem abkommen auf der webseite der
bundesregierung findet ihr die wichtigen
punkte und die drei wichtigsten punkte
die zähle ich mal kurz auf punkt eins in
einer begleitenden entscheidung wird das
versprechen der industrieländer
festgehalten habe 2020 jährlich 100
milliarden dollar für arme staaten
bereit zu stellen diese summe soll bis
2025 fließen punkt 2
die staaten setzten sich das ziel die
erderwärmung im vergleich zum
vorindustriellen zeitalter auf weit
unter zwei grad celsius zu beschränken
es sollen anstrengungen unternommen
werden den temperaturanstieg bereits bei
15 grad zu stoppen
punkt 3 viele entwicklungsländer etwa
die inselstaaten sind durch den
klimawandel bedroht der meeresspiegel
steigt dürrn und unwetter werden
heftiger ihnen wird im pariser abkommen
unterstützung zugesichert etwa durch
frühwarnsysteme und klima
risikoversicherung bis 2020 scheint es
noch ein ganzes stück hin aber vier
jahre gehen eigentlich auch sehr schnell
vorbei und die neue social day
berechnung zeigt erneut die brisanz der
aktuellen lage der diesjährigen ehrt
überlastung tag fiel dieses jahr auf den
achten august vergleicht man dieses
datum mit dem im jahr 2007 wird die
dramatik der lage noch deutlicher damals
wurde in der tat erst am 8 oktober
erreicht um zu beginn des videos
zurückzukehren
es geht schon lange nichts mehr wir
müssen was tun wir müssen unsere art des
konsums und unser verhalten ändern das
hört sich nach viel arbeit an aber zitat
solch eine neue lebensweise ist mit
vielen vorteilen verbunden
doch muss man auch etwas dafür tun so
dass eine klimafreundliche lebensreise
zur norm wird das gute ist dass dies mit
der heutigen technologie möglich und
sogar lukrativ ist die
volkswirtschaftlichen gewinne
überschreiten
kosten dies wird neue
wirtschaftsbereiche stimulieren wie zb
erneuerbare energien oder sogenannte
smart grids also intelligente stromnetze
gleichzeitig reduzieren sich risiken und
kosten von ungeeigneten infrastrukturen
oder vom klima ereignissen das einzige
von dem es noch mehr braucht ist
politischer wille berichtete wackernagel
und da wären wir wieder mal beim
energiewende thema wenn euch das video
gefallen hat lass mir auch gerne einen
daumen nach oben da und ein kostenloses
abo dafür hier klicken
und wenn er hier klickt kommt ihr zu
einem video zum eben angesprochenen
energiewende thema sehr interessant denn
die energiewende ist eigentlich einfach
wie sieht es bei euch aus erlebt ihr
nach der neuen lebensweise und wenn ja
was tut er davor lasst es mich in den
kommentaren wissen und ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran